My very first job in the game
industry was porting a popular PC
flight simulator to the Amiga computer.
This was ages ago.
There was a steep learning curve.
I'd been programming for
maybe ten years,
since junior high school by this time.
But this was my first real
professional programming experience.
I was learning about 93 new
things every single day.
And there were new tools to understand
and libraries and systems to integrate.
Hardware issues and near faces,
not to mention the game itself.
It had been written for a completely
different computer architecture
by some super smart industry vets
including one of the company founders.
Oh, and did I mention, I didn't know
anything about flight simulators?
Well, I remember one of
the first issues I ran into.
There's a problem with the 3D renderer.
On a PC, it worked great.
It was pretty much bulletproof,
super fast.
It had been used in several titles and
it just kept getting better
as it was refined over time.
On the Amiga, though,
the renderer was brand new,
never been used in production.
And, there was a glitch.
Sometimes, unpredictably, a polygon
would tear and it would just blow up and
overwrite half a screen.
Looked terrible.
And since I hadn't written the code and
had no idea how our 3D engine worked,
I wasn't sure how to debug it.
I turned to one of those super smart
industry vets, one of the creators 3D
engine in fact, and asked him for
advice on tracking down this bug.
And he said,
I would just step through all the code.
Well, from my point of view,
this was insane.
I just didn't see how I
could possibly learn and
understand how the system
worked from top to bottom,
which is essentially what he
was telling me I needed to do.
To step through the system and
figure out which part wasn't working,
I had to know what each and
every part did when it was working.
He was right though, and it was hard.
But I learned more than just
how that 3D engine worked.
I learned that I could tackle
a really hard problem and solve it.
You can always look for the easy answer,
but it's important that you not
give up if there isn't one.
You have what it takes to succeed, even
if it doesn't seem like it at first.